this young man is Dakota Semler and he
has it all a flamingo pattern car an
office that couldn't quit 1971 a bunch
of surplus military gear and then this
incredible machine an all-electric semi
truck that is both a salute and a giant
middle finger to Elon Musk
[Music]
Dakota is the CEO of a two-year-old
company called Thor trucks based in
North Hollywood Thor is one of a handful
of companies trying to bring electric
drivetrains to really big vehicles
really we set out to solve the issue
that fleets are having right now with
diesel vehicles a lot of that surrounds
our own compliance maintenance cost the
fuel cost of energy and so we are trying
to set out to solve a lot of those
problems at fleet tab in November
Elon Musk unveiled this sucker at an
event in LA musk said the Tesla semi rig
will cost one hundred eighty thousand
dollars go 500 miles on a single charge
and recharge in about 30 minutes when it
arrives at the end of 2019 I came to
visit Thor to see what a real-life
electric semi can do today Thor got
started in a warehouse when Dakota
bought a diesel truck and hired a team
to convert it they replaced the engine
with an electric motor they built some
battery packs and they slapped a giant
screen in the cab tell me about the logo
it looks almost like Tesla meets
transformers yeah part of what we're
trying to do is really exude kind of the
power that EVs can provide when you
think about EVs particularly when you're
talking about commercial vehicles people
like they're weak they're not strong
Thor's hammer right yeah and it's tough
and it's a brand that people will really
come to be known it's kind of the big
tough TV brand this prototype truck is
called et1
and Tom here agreed to take me out for a
spin with his mustache when I first
looked at the truck I thought
I thought well don't quite know that's
gonna work electric trucks are gonna
cost more than diesel rigs have shorter
driving ranges and require a charging
infrastructure to be built but Tom
thinks they have a chance the way this
st. poles is really more like if nothing
else the truck is good at getting
attention no this is a Thor truck this
is yeah it's electric I'm serious I'll
show it to you no you see the electric
motor Thor expects this truck to cost
$150,000 for 300 miles of range when it
goes on sale in 2019 and they're quiet
run clean and have amazing pickup you
know the power in this thing is
unbelievable the way it takes off and
the way it handles it's
it speaks for itself yeah Thor has 18
employees including a handful with deep
electric vehicle expertise the start-up
bills itself as an electric auto lab
that will make all kinds of custom
vehicles including things like delivery
and garbage trucks Thor will have a hell
of a time going up against giants like
Tesla and Daimler since they have you
know actual factories and experience but
LA has long been home to high-risk
custom auto projects
Tesla's early operations didn't look
much different than these we set up
prototyping tools really early on
because we realized that was a vital
part of being able to build quickly and
and produce something that we could
actually start demonstrating and showing
to customers this warehouse has been a
Dakota's family for three generations
first as a Depot for making and selling
military-grade electronics and that is a
storage spot for the families Malibu
wines vineyard Dakota started working
here when he was seven and eventually
ran the family wine business and started
its safari tours so the Hollywood elite
can get drunk and hang out with giraffes
there's tons of inspiration in this
place tucked in the corner is this
beauty is the 1918 Walker electric panel
van this vehicle was fully electric
battery electric vehicle from the early
turn of the century what did they use it
for so deliveries this was actually one
of like a milk delivery vehicle or an
ice delivery vehicle so this would be a
range of about 15 miles 12 to 15 miles
okay everybody here is incredibly
committed this isn't a project that
we're trying to do or gain a bunch of
notoriety we want to actually make these
things exist in fleets we're actually
driven to to make this viable business
and not just a science project many
things don't pan out Dakota can always
hop in his RV hit the road and go soul
searching for his next venture
I'm sure this beast runs great on
electricity too
you